j'adore cette période de l'année quand
les arbres sont en fleurs et que les
feuilles commencent à éclore c'est un
poirier
elles sont toutes petites mais déjà le
théâtre d'un phénomène extraordinaire
à l'instant où je vous parle les
cellules qui composent la feuille capte
le dioxyde de carbone qui se trouvent
dans l'atmosphère au même moment les
racines puisent de l'eau et des sels
minéraux dans le sol
tous ces éléments remonte dans la
feuille jusqu'aux cellules qui vont
utiliser la lumière du soleil pour
découper ces molécules est ré agencer
les atomes sous forme de sucre qui vont
nourrir la plante
voilà pourquoi on parle de photos
synthèse
ça fait du bien un peu de soleil dans
une capsule de des confiné à les
atteindre 1 et n'oubliez pas nous sommes
confinés
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné
abonnez-vous et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain